and speaking of that
that was an unintended an unintended
Segway the Republican Party
is also in a bad boat
Mike Lindell Kerry Lake
did this very off-the-wall interview
with Steve Bannon they were at the the
Republican winter meeting where they
re-elected Rana Romney McDaniel to be
chairperson of the Republican National
Committee the National Committee she's
once again
the chair of
and this came to Great consternation for
the the my pillow goof who wanted he he
was in the running along with a lawyer
out of San Francisco Maine named Harmony
Dylan
and uh they both lost to to Rana Romney
McDaniel she she lost the Romney because
Donald Trump didn't like it but I you
know I'm just that penny I'm going to
continue to call her Rana Romney
McDaniel
but this this clip that I'm going to
play for you of the the Bannon
interviewing both Carrie Lake and Mike
Lindell sitting side by side is just
bizarre and it's not bizarre for the
fact that the background is actually
more blurry than Carrie Lake's face
usually is it's bizarre because they're
doing the thing that I've been talking
about uh very recently but also for
months that the rhetoric surrounding not
having a country anymore the rhetoric
surrounding our Republic being just a
failed State the rhetoric surrounding us
losing our sovereignty is being whipped
up into a frenzy by these particular
Fringe clowns watch this
Ronald
McDaniel has not you've been there for
three days Ronald McDaniel has not
pulled you aside and said let's have a
cup of coffee and spend five minutes
together have you guys spent any time
with each other one-on-one
no we have an unfortunate and and you
know what I do want to reach out to her
because here's what's going on and I
know that this might not be the popular
View
Rana one and full stop you should you
shouldn't have to reject you shouldn't
have to reach out to Ronald McDaniel
you're the freaking governor of Arizona
you just won an incredibly tough race
because you stood for policies that Maga
stands for she should be blowing your
phone up every day can I get five
minutes this is outrageous but but
here's what I'm willing to do I'm
willing to meet with her and say let's
move forward because this next election
if we do not get president Donald Trump
back in the white house I don't know how
much longer we can last and I think our
Republic is in Peril I will do
everything in my power if that means I
can't come across the country whatever
it means I want to get president Trump
if we don't get you in Arizona if we
don't get you in Arizona now I'm not
going to sure we have sovereignty
all of that is alarming because one
they're just leaning into the conspiracy
theory that Kerry Lake won the election
you shouldn't have to wait for Ronda Ron
McDaniel to call you you're the governor
of of Arizona
It's News to the rest of the country
Steve Bannon Steve Bannon who has has
his hands in the attempted coup in
Brazil Steve Bannon who had his hand
deeply in to the Insurrection at the
United States Capitol on January 6 2021.
the attempted overthrow of the United
States government partly many believe
orchestrated planned and executed by
Steve Bannon and his colleagues
and here he is again trying to whip up
the base by using language like this and
she doesn't jettison it she doesn't
swatted away she Embraces it
this next election if we don't get
Donald Trump back in the white house I
don't know how much longer we can last I
think our Republic is in Peril she says
that that is strong language that whips
clowns like David depap the guy who was
talking about the the tree of Liberty
needing watered by the blood of patriots
is what would follow
it's those types of people who have
violent tendencies who have a proclivity
to to radicalism they're going to be
animated by language like this
and he shuts her down on the Trump thing
he says no no no if we don't get you in
Arizona now I'm not sure we're going to
have sovereignty
all of this is problematic and all of
this should should animate you
to want to make a difference in this
upcoming election look I know it seems
like oh we just got through the midterms
2024 is too far away to really worry
about that it is not you need to talk to
your friends to your neighbors to your
family to your co-workers hell to the
dude you sit next to at the bus stop and
talk to them about this type of thing
because if we can animate one person
each and they can animate one person we
can overwhelm Republicans at the polls
to ensure that we don't lose our
sovereignty that we don't lose our
Republic that it absolutely is in Peril
but not for the reasons that Kerry Lake
says
once again I am Jesse dollimore thank
you for joining me you can follow me on
Twitter I am at Dollar Moore there and
Twitter and Instagram and Tick Tock I'm
on uh YouTube dollar more daily or just
search my stupid name you'll find me
there I'd love to have you subscribe and
uh be a regular Watcher of my mouth that
flaps in my face that gets red when I
get angry
oh
anyway I'll see you next time thanks a
lot one of our sponsors today is mosh
whether you're at the gym on the go
between meals mosh protein bars are the
smart snack to keep your body and brain
fueled there's six delicious flavors
like blueberry almond crunch peanut
butter chocolate Crunch cookie dough
crunch each mosh bar comes packed with
12 grams of protein 6 grams of fiber but
also important nutrients like vitamin B
vitamin D
Omega-3s and only one gram of sugar and
160 calories I've tried tons of
different protein bars really you can't
beat the taste and the texture of mosh I
love these my favorite is the chocolate
Crunch simple satisfying now that I'm
back in the gym I'll snack on one of
these after a workout mosh is also a
mission-driven company with a portion of
all proceeds donated to support women's
brain health research through the the
women's Alzheimer's movement at
Cleveland Clinic mosh is giving my
audience 20 off plus free shipping on
your first six count trial pack go to
moshlife.com Pacman the link is down
below